we are here to document the lives of
people living in Alaska the harsh
reality is the environment we're up
against it makes it tough to do our job
working on life below zero can be very
dangerous guns here cameras you never
know what to expect you do that
gonna be tough but we're gonna get the
shot every scenario we got to prepare
for this but we're still smiling her
having fun still making like below zero
yes bring it on
[Music]
well we're back in Inez now you got to
get that necessities for us which is
some heat we restrict the temperatures
anywhere from I don't know - 20 30 when
it gets this cold you burn a lot of wood
to stay warm we're gonna drop this tree
right down there yeah right between
these two big spruces here you don't
want to just cut down any tree and you
find a good debt tree that's standing
dead tree which is nice dry wood which
will burn like a you know like a monster
[Music]
good what are you doing where's that
crotch there oh it's gonna have enough
weight it's going to punch right through
it bro I'm gonna try to cut it over here
and leave all the wood over here and try
to put it right where I want it though
all right
well I got it on that side yeah you did
boom took her down and that literally
one tree is gonna keep us going for
probably you know nearly a week depends
how cold it gets
[Music]
the Brett just built a quite a big trees
bucking it up now into like eight foot
lengths I'm gonna pull the snowmobile
around and just start loading it up we
hope to get it you know three four feet
high before we can get comfy and start
our filming here we need to be able to
have enough heat to maintain us for a
couple days at least before we have to
stop again and replenish our supplies I
think Andy's gonna be impressed that's
all I have to say as you can see one
tree really does the job right that we
aren't even done with that tree right
another load like this probably now we
do we have another load for it
it was hard work you know knee-deep in
the snow and heft in these little hooks
in your shoulders and moving them around
at least we can start up a roaring fire
right when we get back it's cold it's
unpredictable and we don't know we're
gonna get here we are currently in a
Tucker we're out filming sue as she
takes her generator to keV ik this is
the crew one that we're filming in right
now but we just we've literally got
three miles and we've just got it stuck
so it's going to be long turning but
first things first we're gonna need to
help get this thing unstuck it's cold
out warm up boys
as you can see we have pretty much stuck
we have come out with two Tucker's this
is a river right here we just sunk into
some serious overflow so Sue's one's
gonna have to try and get us out right
now because obviously we aren't going
nowhere
that's pretty deep actually entirely
sure whether it was going to get out at
all the wind is picking up
it's about minus 15 right now leading to
get it out of here before it freezes in
there otherwise I'm ain't moving at all
there's a big rush against time right
now too so they're going to try and dig
out all the excess snow and kind of get
it out there quick till that's over for
if it freezes ain't moving
we got it up freakin awesome
look at that hole that made that's the
same karate so just a few minutes ago
this was fully submerged so it got a
bunch of snow piled up inside this track
you got to free this up so that this
thing could move and the track could do
its job
all that snows off this track they'll
have roughly 70 miles to go in this
journey so hopefully we'll just be able
to carry on a note akattak pray that we
don't run into any more overflow or any
other obstacles last thing you want is
to be stuck in the mineral know where
hopefully we could just keep chugging
along and get the kavik and finish out
our story
[Music]